- So Shannon, I have to ask you,
what are some of the small gestures
that have made a big
difference in your journey
that somebody has done
that people didn't realize
that might've been small to them,
but it really mattered to you.
- I think the people sharing their own
cancer journeys on my Instagram.
- Yeah.
- Did a lot for me. I, you know,
like maybe I did for you,
- Absolutely.
- It was the people sharing it from me
because it was, it was
people going through it
who had gone through it,
sort of letting me know that
they were there for me saying,
Hey, you know, like I posted a photo of
during chemo and I got really sick
and I had to get rushed and get IV and,
you know, hydrated and everything else.
And they were like, listen,
we've been through this.
You're going to be fine.
You're going to get through this.
So I think all that sort of
strength and that support
really, really helped me.
And again, it goes back to like, yes,
Social Media can be a beautiful,
beautiful, beautiful thing
- Yeah.
- if used the right if used the right way.
- That beautiful connection. Absolutely.